[Music]
Wow
it's hard to believe it's been only a
year since we launched their bundle here
at i/o and what an incredible year it
was
I'm your feed with her a product manager
with the play London team and I'm Martin
a software engineer on Google Play in
London so today we're going to talk
about what's new this year in the world
of Android app bundles so many
developers have bought into our vision
of to optimize tailored delivery and
have already migrated to the app bundle
this includes some of the most popular
apps on Play seeing incredible size
savings that range from around 10
percent to 60 percent versus delivering
a universal apk we really couldn't have
hoped for a better acceptance of the app
bundle among the developer community and
Google apps are migrating as well so
this includes apps such as photos maps
and YouTube which have dramatically
reduced their app size having switched
to the bundle so how is this achieved
let's take a look back and remind
ourselves what the app bundle is so in
essence the app bundle is a new
publishing format that replaces the
traditional monolithic apk but the app
bundle is not installable directly
instead play generates apk is optimized
for specific devices from the single
bundle up late
these apks are much smaller than if the
developer were to deploy a single apk
for everyone but the single app load
provides a much simpler developer
experience than uploading multiple apks
so how does this work
so the smaller download size is achieved
by delivering only the resources from
the app that the specific devices need
deploying a single ap Caid would result
in all languages densities and native
architectures being delivered for all
the devices but as we see here with the
app bundle only the relevant languages
densities and native architectures are
delivered yielding a smaller install on
the device and the first to download so
on average the app bundle yields a 20%
reduction in app size this leads to
faster downloads which leads to an 11%
increase in install successes because
there are fewer chances for the download
to fail
and since less disk space is used it
also leads to a reduction in uninstalls
so since launched more than 80 thousand
apps have moved over to the app vandal
those apps and I publishing a single
bundle and relying on play to deliver
smaller apks to specific devices
tailored for them but this is just the
beginning the introduction of the app
bundle opens the door for new and
exciting delivery features that simply
wouldn't have been possible before
with the a bundle we can build towards a
vision of tailored delivery that
optimizes all aspects of your observing
from which part of your app to serve to
whom and when in order to take the a
bundle to the next level we are giving
you greater control and that's why our
main topic today is customizable
delivery which puts you in control over
how your app is being delivered this
will allow us to fully realize the
potential of the app bundle as it's you
who knows your app and users best today
we'll cover four new product offerings
that demonstrate the concept of
customizable delivery in app updates
that lets you target updates directly
from your traditional delivery that lets
you choose which feature module to
deliver to which devices on-demand
delivery that allows you to call for
features only when you need them and ask
a delivery for game that expands the a
bundle to include game content letting
you package your game assets alongside
video game binary and publish a single
artifact to play we'll also talk about
internal actually that gives you an easy
way to share test build with your
testers over to Martin to talk about
in-app updates our first product
offering for today thanks your feet so
auto updates are really great for
seamlessly keeping your users up to date
not all users receive them summer never
on Wi-Fi others may simply have Auto
updates turned off so some users end up
using old versions of the app now this
isn't great for developers for one thing
there may be a critical bug fix that you
really need to get out to all your users
a new and strategic feature you're
rolling out a multiplayer game where you
need to have all of your players on the
same version of the app or perhaps
you're simply looking to ditch support
for very old versions of the app now
in-app updates which we're launching
today gives you a way to trigger updates
of your app directly from your app it
gives you control over the right context
to your moment to start an update while
keeping the user in the app and not
risking additional friction so in-app
updates come in two flavors an immediate
flow that triggers the update right away
requiring minimal integration this is
because play handles the user experience
during the update and the flexible flow
that lets you customize the user
experience during the update this
requires more thinking and design work
but is ultimately much more customizable
so let's took let's take a look at both
of these flavors in action so first
we'll take a look at the immediate
in-app update flow with our sample
recipe finder app so as we can see here
the app triggers an update and the user
is kept in a manage flow until the
update finishes so first the user
confirms that they want to take the
update and the download size is revealed
to the user then the update is
downloaded during which Play manages the
user experience as we see here once the
update is downloaded and ready for
install it is applied and control is
returned to the new up-to-date shiny
version of the app then the user can
continue their journey inside the app
now here the developer doesn't need to
do anything beyond the initial trigger
of the update which can happen when the
developer chooses now some developers
will want more customized ability than
this so here we have swiggy swiggy is a
food delivery app popular in India with
more than 10 million downloads now many
of their users aren't regularly on Wi-Fi
and so can't benefit
from auto updates but by using in-app
updates they can prompt the user to
update while they're in the app and they
have the users attention so as we see
here swiggy have incorporated a small
alert icon that notifies the user that
the update is available then when the
user investigates they're prompted with
an opportunity to do in their map update
once again clay seeks confirmation by
displaying the download size but for
this flow once the user is accepted
control is returned immediately back to
the app and the user can continue to use
the app while the update is being
downloaded finally when the update is
ready clay will inform the app again and
the app can do something appropriate for
example here swiggy raises a snack bar
which provides the opportunity for the
user to complete the update by
restarting the app again into the new
shiny version of the app so the flexible
in-app update flow provides the
developer the opportunity to customize
the experience during the in-app update
so next let's take a look how this looks
like in code so first we acquire an
instance of an app update manager from
the Play color library this is an object
that lets you interact with the in-app
update API we make a call to find out
whether an update is available if it is
then we can act appropriately
perhaps triggering the in-app update
flow immediately or perhaps rendering
some button that will do so once clicked
now the Java play core API for in-app
updates that we see here is available
for any app to use today in play core
1.5 but in the future we'll be adding
extension libraries for integration with
cotton and jetpack leading to even
simpler code and if you're interested in
seeing that there was a live demo in the
developer keynote so that's enough
updates Thank You Marty
now let's talk about how to adjust the
way your app is installed in the first
place traditionally all your code and
app content are always served to all
users but sometimes you have features
that are simply not applicable to some
of the users or some of the devices so
by including them your users gets part
of your app that they will never use
this is obviously not ideal conditional
delivery lets you control which part of
your R would be served to which users
with conditional delivery you can set a
set of conditions under which a feature
module would be delivered and otherwise
will be left out this this lets you
exclude certain part of your from some
of the devices and avoid loading your
app with irrelevant features to the
device its installed on optimizing
download side and on device footprint of
your we support three types of
conditions for conditional delivery
first you can hang of a modular included
only for specific countries this is the
first time play has let you targets part
of your app this way
second you can restrict the module by
minimum SDK version targeting only
devices above a certain version and
third you can deliver your module only
to devices that support a certain
feature such as a br hearten configuring
condition of delivery is super easy once
you've extracted the feature into a
module the only change needed is adding
installation instructions to the
androidmanifest.xml the newly introduced
install time elements allow you to
specify conditions for delivery you can
include conditions for device feature
user country and min SDK we additionally
support minimum OpenGL ES version if you
leave the install time element empty
the model would always be delivered in
this example the liver is conditioned by
device feature and min SDK and the
module will be served only to endless
devices they have na our camera these
are our country condition lets you
exclude or include a module in specific
countries and you can specify more than
one country here the model will be
deployed only to you the United States
and Britain the device country in this
context is typically determined by the
user billing address attached to the
Google Play account as we've seen
conditions may be combined and all
conditions must be met for a module to
be delivered at runtime you can K you
can call Lake or API get installed
module to find out meet which modules
are installed this can be used for
example to guard access to a certain
activity contained in the conditional
module once the app is installed
conditional modules can also be
requested to record even if conditions
weren't originally met this is useful
for example when you want a specific
module - Bitzer
only - some of the users by default will
still have while still letting other use
it
users get it upon request Martin will
talk next on how such features can be
called for on demand thanks so--that's
modules that are conditional it in still
time but sometimes at install time you
simply do not know whether a module is
relevant for a user
perhaps this depends on your individual
knowledge of the user or their behavior
inside the app after install so what can
you do then on demand feature modules
can be used to install and remove
modules during the lifetime of an app
based on user behavior inside the app
triggered via code for example this
might be useful for user driven uploads
in a consumption app which might only be
used by a subset of the most engaged
users
other use cases might be an onboarding
flow or a customer support flow that are
rarely used more than once so let's
explore a case study Netflix so Netflix
is customer support flow is a feature
used only by a small subset of their
users and is rarely used more than once
by an individual user but it is a fairly
big component of the app at a few
megabytes so it's a perfect use case for
a feature module delivered on demand
when the user clicks on the customer
support option the module is downloaded
and installed and once installed it
seamlessly opens and the user can
connect to customer support this flow is
live in Netflix today now in future
Netflix will also configure installed
modules in other ways for example it can
remove the onboarding flow once the
onboarding flow is completed so how
might that look so let's take a look at
the code here so let's consider how
removing a module would looking kid like
this so first the module is considered
configured as an unconditional install
time module so this is a dynamic feature
that's extracted and separate from the
rest of the app but it's installed for
everyone when the app is installed but
by keeping it separate when the time is
right it can be removed in code via the
split install API in play core the Play
Store will then mark the module for
removal and remove it before too long
saving precious disk space now on demand
and conditional modules our engine
general availability today and can be
used in any app so we talked a lot about
customizing delivery of feature modules
but the reality is that many times the
bulk of the content is actually coming
from assets and not code this is
especially true through games which
sometimes require a massive content
download to even get the user start
playing we know that many of you are
using steady and solutions to host and
deliver your content from but this
result in a sub optimal user
Corrine's user install and open the game
reddit's to start playing just to be
faced with the long progress bar waiting
for additional resources to be
downloaded furthermore since the city
end is blind to the device asking for
the content it can optimize delivery to
the requesting client so you end up
serving all assets to all users
regardless if they will ever use them
another major downside of using a CDN is
the silicon you can't rely on other
updates of assets so again this results
in additional long wait for updating
resources after the game is already
installed to make asset delivery
seamless we'll be releasing a new set of
delivery option suited for games with a
we are extending the a bundle format to
include game assets introducing a whole
new delivery construct the ancestor
unlike feature modules as effects are
composed of assets only with no
executable code and can be very large
assessments will be packaged in the app
bundle alongside your game binary so you
can publish a single artifact to play
containing everything your game needs
you can also rely on a plague to take
care of keeping your assets up to date
just like it currently does with your
game binary and similarly to the
flexibility you have with feature
modules you will be able to customize
asset delivery according to your game
needs to start you can use this to serve
your assets up front as part of the
initial install instead of using apk
expansion files as effects served this
way won't require to publish an
additional artifact to play and unlike
extension files are not prone to extent
a deletion by the user or other acts
your assets can be easily accessed like
any assets packaged in the base apk
using Android assets manager
you can sign up today for early access
program at this link and we'll soon be
able to include up to one gigabyte of
your game assets in the abandon avoiding
the additional complexity of using apk
expansion files but again this is just
the first step
stay tuned for further announcements
later this year about additional
delivery options which will give you
even greater flexibility in control and
allow larger answer fats and up and
enable optimize device targeting so then
for game assets as well your users will
get only the assets suitable for their
advice so let's recap the features we've
discussed so far today you can trigger
updates directly from your app without
having your users go to the store you
can condition the delivery of feature
modules and you can call for features on
demand and soon you'll be able to
package up to one gigabyte of your game
assets in the app bundle and serve it as
part of the game installation but a lot
of what we touched on today relies on
having your app broken up broken up into
modules so to fully benefit from all
this greatness you should consider
modernizing your arm let's thank Marty
and have been from our developer
relations team get a little deeper on a
polarization will then talk about our
last product announcement for today
internal up sharing
ectopy wow that's a lot of weight new
ways to delete to shape your app to your
users but like if he just said in order
to make the most of it your app has to
be modular eyes traditionally an app was
served to a user's device as a single
monolithic apk that contained all the
code and resources and all the features
to run all of your app with the Android
app bundle yet it uses the split apk
functionality introduced in android
lollipop makes use of this so we can
make all use of all the features that we
have seen today instead of packaging
everything into one single monolithic
apk multiple configuration apks are
being built then some of them suiting
the users devices and preferences will
be installed on your users device this
already saves you user precious data you
can achieve this by simply building your
Android app as an app bundle and
releasing it on a play store so far no
changes to your code are required but it
already will lead to decreased
installation size and faster downloads
but I'm here to talk about modular
ization so we let's take a look at what
we did with an app that we made in our
sample app for modularized apps we've
gone through a process with plaid it's
an app that we used to showcase a lot of
features throughout years we used it for
material design - animations and
transitions and most recently dart mode
also throughout the past year we added
we made major changes to the app and
modularized it and add a dependency
injection using dagger the app consists
of a home feet that Gaza displays gather
information they also has a search
functionality and about screen and
several new sources that can be turned
on and off in the end these user facing
features will be our future module but
before we started modularizing
we switched over to our bundles this
allowed us to save a staggering 2/3 of
the storage on some users devices
we ship a native library and by only
having to ship the library for the CPU
architecture that is installed on we
save a lot of that a lot of data already
from there we were able to make changes
to actually the structure Platt has
usually your app consists of multiple
things that high-end together of code
resources external dependencies and
drawables after modularizing
the compiler will have in will enforce
clean boundaries between your future
modules through a directed dependency
graph so let's take a look how we did
that with implant no matter how to
restructure your code overall within the
app no matter which architecture you
choose you break that down into the into
future modules beforehand before we
actually started making future modules
we put everything into packages per
feature this allowed for a clean
separation of concerns already during
that we started untangling unwanted
dependencies and in the end none of the
future modules should import code from
another feature module directly then we
ran look at our resources we were
particularly interested in structuring
in them in a way that we can move them
to modules later on as well without
problems so for Strings we initially
created files with a naming convention
that reflect the feature feature
Association we chose to add a module
name as a prefix that way they still
show up grouped together in the IDE we
then move the features move the strings
into these feature resource files as we
went along
we also renamed layouts drawables
attributes in the same way and then move
them along this list of with shared
sources which we moved in to share
dependency called our core library the
core library is bundled once within the
app space module and can be expanded I
can be exposed to dynamic feature
modules this means the entire
application is able to access
dependencies without unnecessarily
adding to the app size at this point
everything still was one monolithic
module but since we structured our app
on a feature level we were able to go
and creator of real first dynamic
feature module we started using the most
lightweight module with the least shared
dependencies our about screen the
Android Studios new module dialog takes
care of creating the basic setup all we
have to do is enter a module name and a
package name directories are being
created and the correct dependencies are
added in the apps Gradle file then we
moved all the previously structured code
and resources in the about feature into
a newly created module for most cases it
was a fairly lightweight process but
someday let's take a little bit more
work and thinking about so let's talk
about these as we are using resources
from both the about feature as well as
from the coal library imports came from
different our files they became a bit
tedious to read in a monolithic
application you usually have one single
of these files so that's not a problem
but if you import for multiple for
multiple packages you can end up with
imports like this we're able to resolve
this with courtland's import aliasing
it's a feature it allows you to map an
import to another name so instead of
having to write a fully qualified import
for apps our class we simply mapped it
to a bar this led to more concise and
readable code differentiation is still
possible and easy but it's way less
noisy to read another thing we had to
change was the way activities are
launched within the app in a monolithic
app it's possible to pass the class pass
the class directly truly intend
explicitly even activities within a
library dependency can be explicitly
launched the dependency is directly
accessible from within the app space
module but a dynamic feature module
depends on the app which makes its
content invisible to the app module
this means the classes in a dynamic
feature module are inaccessible to the
app module so instead of passing the
class directly we now pass the fully
qualified class name the android flight
framework is able to instantiate and
start the activity as it usually did an
app containing fragments in a dynamic
feature module can use reflection for
instantiation a key to model arising is
also having a single point of
for actions you can take so we didn't
want to maintain these weekly cut type
calls throughout the entirety of plaid
so we introduced the addressable
addressable activity interface in the
apps core library then we implemented it
for each of plaids activities when
needed these objects can also hold keys
to enter nectar extras in a single place
this allows for centralized code that
can be invoked from anyone view
alongside with the intent to phone
function this makes launching the
activity for straightforward and type
safe this allows for decoupled code that
can be invoked from any module as well
as easy to read even before making use
of on-demand delivery we have reaped
various benefits Platts built time
dropped from three minutes down to one
minute for a clean build this is
achieved by using Grails to parallel
build feature which enables us to build
multiple independent features at once up
to a certain limit separating out more
independent features will further
decrease the build time overall we
gained a more maintainable app this is
due to self-contained modules and
compile time enforcement of separation
also apps footprint has dramatically
decreased this results in a faster and
faster app downloads and saves precious
storage on device so looking back at our
tracks we took so far we first
identified the features of the app that
we wanted to model arise in our case
those were the user facing features that
the app already had then we started
moving the code and resources to match
to the structure afterwards
we created a future module and populated
that our modular architecture will allow
us in the future to dynamically install
modules as we need them this works by
depending on the pleco library and
making use of its functionality we can
request an emic feature modules as they
are needed and start installing them
also
if users disable features for a longer
time we can easily uninstall them if
they're no longer needed for more
details on how to do it check out the
sample app as well as the play core
library documentation you can follow
Platts development on github also check
out an article containing more in-depth
information on the modular ization
process
thank you very much with better without
back to your feet
[Applause]
now let's talk about testing a bit since
we launched the app bundle we kept
hearing from developers how great it is
but there is one thing we heard from you
loud and clear
testing of the app bundle is hard this
is especially true early in the
development lifecycle
where you simply want to share a test
build with your interests internal
testers in the apk world it used to be
very easy to do you simply send the apk
and the platform knows what to do with
it but our bundles are not installable
and would play tailoring the served up
to each device you want a guaranteed way
to get exactly the same binary as your
users would get you have asked and we
have heard you internal app sharing
launched today gives you a quick and
easy way to internally share our bundles
for testing all you need to do is up is
upload a bundle to play get a shareable
you around and have your testers use
that to your realm to download and test
the app this is how it looks you simply
drag and drop to upload and share the
generated link with your testers with
internal app sharing the app installed
is exactly the same as if it would have
officially published to play it even
supports dynamic delivery features
including on-demand and conditional
delivery this way you have full
confidence that what you are testing is
the real thing any and you can expect
exactly the same behavior as your users
out in the world you are probably
curious to hear more about how it works
so let's have search who led the
development of internal app sharing
dive into the details of it
[Applause]
thanks Fe hello first I'd like to
clarify that internal app sharing is
fundamentally different than our
existing testing programs simply put
it's not a release track with internal
app sharing the test version uploaded to
play or served and hosted by play
independently they're not part of a
release published in the Play console so
let's start a few important features
first each test version each uploaders
don't need to be click on show members
so you can authorize users that don't
have access to the Play Store test
versions are we signed by play with the
test certificate so uploaders don't need
access to the production or upload key
of your app play doesn't require unique
version codes so multiple uploaders can
use this feature and apparently and they
don't have to pick unique version codes
when they upload the bugaboo artifacts
can also be uploaded so you can debug
the apk is once installed on the testers
devices to authorize testers you can go
to the Play console and choose to either
allow anyone with the link to download
and install apks or to allow only users
in in predefined list in both cases
there's a user cap enforced by play so
let me show you how it works in practice
can we switch to the laptop please
can we can we seal at the lab yes
excellent so I have an app bundle here
on my desktop I just did a fix for a bug
that was reported and I want to quickly
share it with my QA engineer for
validation obviously because it's an app
bundle
my tester cannot simply install it on
the device so what I will do is that I
will load the new internal app sharing
upload page and then we'll drag and drop
the bundle on to that page against here
I don't have to worry about version
codes because I'm guaranteed they won't
conflict with the artifact published in
release tracks it shows a dialog and it
shows the version name of my app bundle
that is extracted from the Android
manifest file I can choose to change the
version name so my tester knows what
this test version is about here again my
tester my uploader account doesn't need
to have access to the Play console it
just needs to be authorized by the Play
console admin for that app now that the
upload has completed it shows a
shareable link so I can copy that link
and I can send it to my tester I can we
can we switch to the device place
amazing so I have my testers device here
and within a few seconds I should get
the email so my tester opens the link
and install the app
so there it is super simple okay this is
a version of Gmail that I built and I
changed it so that there's a dynamic
feature module for the compose activity
when I tap on the plus button here it
loves a feature module and it's
installed by play it works right away
because the app is installed by play but
even better because my bundle is the
Bugaboo I can take my device and I can
connect it to Android studio I can
attach the debugger to that process and
I can step through the dynamic delivery
code so that's super useful can you all
sorry can we switch to the can we switch
to the both devices please all right let
me do that again I can step and through
the dynamic delivery code more than that
we also build an API endpoint and the
Play publisher API so that you can
automate publishing artifact to internal
app sharing and you can integrate it
with third-party tools so you can even
for instance invoke it directly for
management studio so this is play
internal app sharing thank you very much
thank you sir so just in case you've
missed it using internal app sharing
search was able to locally debug dynamic
delivery of an on-demand feature isn't
that cool we hope that this presentation
demonstrated our commitment to the a
bundle and that we are doubling down on
a vision of customized dynamic delivery
in app updates conditional delivery
dynamic delivery and internal sharing
our old life with documentation
available at
developer.android.com/design
join our early program at the link we'll
have more to share later this year so
come and see us at event like the
Android developer summit and Google Play
time thank you
[Music]